uh initially while we watched the video
we noticed that the suspect who is seen
here to my left is wearing a black puffy
jacket was wearing a black
pants appears to have brown boots and a
black fedora on his head he's also
wearing a surgical mask
this is the initial information that we
had and we began a very extensive canvas
of the entire area
reference the video the video clearly
based on the angle we have it shows the
attack that occurs and it is very uh
horrific what occurs to the victim in
this case who's a 57 year old white
female
um
right right now i'm going to provide you
video from the video canvas that we did
where we began to start tracking the
suspects movements through the location
so
the initial video where you see the mail
turn the corner that is from an
apartment complex that's located just to
the east
of where the crime occurred and that's
after the murder occurred the video
that's going on right now at the
sidewalk this is at the location of the
crime
based on that we were able to continue
to track the subject's movements as we
begin
but we lose him through the video
surveillance efforts in the area of
rochelle and caliente
that is where we begin to lose where he
was at we began extensive canvas on
person for the following weekend as we
begin contacting residents in the area
trying to identify anyone that might
know who this person is that is wearing
the black puffy jacket at that point in
time